[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition involving the Masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to bury business is to
model the strategies of people who have
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at how a young
man went from selling garbage bags to
becoming a billionaire entrepreneur and
a really outspoken one at that this is a
story of Dallas Mavericks NBA owner Mark
Cuban and a top three lessons you can
learn from his success Mark Cuban is the
well-known outspoken and brash owner of
the Dallas Mavericks NBA basketball team
who wears his heart on his sleeve and as
a result is prone to many publicized
outbursts but the billionaire Cuban is
also an entrepreneur at heart having
created more startups in his early years
than most others in a lifetime however
this is not the way Cuban started out
his upbringing was middle-class and with
a housewife for a mother and his father
and uncle working in an upholstery shop
he began selling garbage bags local
residents at the age of 12 and this was
the start of his entrepreneurship career
he graduated from Mount Lebanon High
School in 1976 but not before
establishing a reputation as a hustler
looking back Cuban guesses that his
classmates would have predicted he would
either wind up in jail or owning a
business thankfully it was the latter
that would prove to be correct cuban got
his first real job selling franchises
for a company called tronics 2000 a TV
repair shop he left after just four
months when his idea to branch out into
computer repairs was met with rejection
they didn't see a future in computers
cuban recalls unemployed cuban began to
ask himself what kind of business he
could start on his own i saw an ad for
somebody selling powdered milk and i
thought everybody needs milk like they
need garbage bags he said so cuban
created a company to sell powdered milk
but it was a self-admitted disaster
after four failed businesses he began
working for your business software a 90
company but was later fired cuban
convinced some of its other employees to
leave the company and join him in his
later venture micro solutions it would
be a systems integrator and reseller for
various IT companies including IBM an
apple
in just eight years the company had sold
over 500 networks that ranged in size
from two to over a thousand users by
investing in cutting-edge technology and
providing outstanding customer service
Marko solutions had become a major
player in the promising new IT industry
so major that in 1990 Cubans sold the
company the CompuServe for six million
dollars cuban was 32 years old and a
millionaire he decided to take an early
retirement but it wouldn't be long
before his entrepreneurial instincts
kicked in and brought him back into the
game
in 1995 together with college buddy Todd
Wagner cuban created a company called
audio net totally missing the games of
their college basketball team cuban and
wagner created audio net which used new
streaming technology to broadcast sports
games over the Internet
in 1998 Audio net became broadcast comm
and the company went public at the time
and had the largest single-day gain in
the history of the stock market with
over 330 employees and annual revenues
in a neighborhood of a hundred million
dollars cuban sold the company to Yahoo
for 5.7 billion dollars in stock in 2000
cubic purchased the Dallas Mavericks for
285 million dollars and immediately set
out to revive the team with courtside
presence at every game and his outspoken
and passionate nature Cuban quickly
became a fan favorite
by not giving up and by bouncing back
after lots of failures
Mark Cuban was able to go from selling
garbage bags to becoming a billionaire
entrepreneur and turned his life around
to help you turn your business around
here are the top three action items and
lessons you can learn from Mark Cuban
action item number one know more than
everyone else if you want people to buy
from you they have to trust you to get
them to trust you it helps to know what
you're talking about
take the time to research and know more
about your industry than your
competitors do it'll give you an
advantage when your position in your
business as well as convince buyers that
they're going with the right person by
choosing you throat University Cuban was
a self-proclaimed party animal he shared
a three-bedroom apartment with five
other guys who all had a routine of
buying cheap bottles of champagne to
last him the whole night sleeping
arrangements were determined based on
how late they each got home that all
changed when Cuban landed his first job
with your business software he was
excited to be finally beginning a job
that might actually hold a promising
career ahead but he was also scared
instead of giving in to his fear Cuban
decided to do his homework each night he
would bring home a different software
manual and read it no matter how late it
was
soon Cuban found that he was not only
actually able to adequately answer his
customers questions about the software
but he was also building a clientele
from internet streaming to basketball to
high-definition television juban did his
homework to understand what his
opportunities were according to Cuban
I've never worked with an IBM PC in my
life or calls Cuban not a single time
and I'm going to be selling software for
it turns out not a lot of people ever
bothered to read the freaking manual so
people started really thinking I knew my
stuff everyone has ideas the hard part
is doing the homework to know if the
idea could work in the industry then
doing the preparation to be able to
execute on the idea do your homework and
know your business better than anyone
otherwise someone who knows more and
works harder will kick your ass action
dial number two don't use shortcuts you
can speed up your entrepreneurial
journey by modeling success but at the
end of the day you still have to do the
work
successful entrepreneurs work hard
you have to work smart but you also have
to work hard when Cuban first started
his company micro solutions that was
just about all he did he sacrificed his
personal life his hobbies and much of
his own money in order to get this
business on its feet he didn't take a
vacation for seven years and except for
his to motivational favorites he would
never even made the time to read a
fictional book during those seven years
but for Cuban there was no other choice
he knew that in order to succeed he
would have to work twice as hard as the
next guy it's this quality the Cuban not
only tries to embody himself but that he
looks for in others when he hires in
order to succeed Cuban stresses the
importance of recognizing one's own
strengths and weaknesses there are no
shortcuts to success according to cuban
there are no shortcuts everyone tells
you how they're gonna be special but few
do the work to get there do the work you
have to work hard and try to put
yourself in a position where if luck
strikes you can see the opportunity and
take advantage of it there's always
going to be someone out there that knows
they have to compensate for maybe having
less talent with harder work and
preparation make sure you're brutally
honest with yourself about who you are
you may think that you're more talented
than the next guy which is exactly what
the next guy thinks as well work like
there's someone working 24 hours a day
to take it all away from you and play
like it's your last chance to play
action little number three learn from
your failures builders happen to every
successful entrepreneur if you look back
on a career of any famous entrepreneur
you'll find failures don't let failure
keep you down one venture might not work
but it doesn't mean you're not going to
be a successful entrepreneur keep
reaching out learn from your mistakes
and start again more smartly if you
don't let failure keep you down you will
know success despite being a billionaire
by the time he reaches early 40s
Cubans path to success was fraught with
difficulties from his futile garbage bag
business to his failed powdered milk
venture to being fired from his first
real job Cuban had experienced so much
disappointment in his early years that
even he was doubtful as to whether he
would find success in any career
it was also cut from his high school
basketball team and had numerous credit
cards caught up in front of his face he
learned that you don't have to get it
right the first time
Cupid never gave up on his dream of
running his own business he continued to
work towards his goal and knew that it
would only take one successful business
to make up for all his previous failed
attempts instead of letting his failures
get the better of him he went took each
as a learning opportunity
according to cuban always remember that
no matter how many times you get shot
down you will get smarter better and you
only have to be right once to be
successful I'm always afraid of failure
it's great motivation to work harder
rejection has only been a distraction
not a roadblock every no gets me closer
to it yes
was the saying I used to use all that
matters in business is that you get it
right once then everyone can tell you
how lucky you are
so remember know more than anyone else
don't use shortcuts and learn from your
failures to finish up this video I
wanted to share one of my favorite true
stories of Mark Cuban and some of his
best quotes Mark Cuban have been failing
at almost every career he tried before
the age of 30 would start a business and
it would fail would get a job and then
he'd get fired who would go broke and
stay that way until he found something
that would pay the bills
according to cuban it was so bad that
his parents are worried about what he
was going to do for the rest of his life
however that worry was not something
that they coddled they continued to push
him and knew that eventually he would
find his niche he was struggling
financially when he was fired from your
business software but this gave him his
first real business idea that worked he
would later say that his parents always
made him work harder than everyone else
and teach him never to give up that's
what he did and became a billionaire
because of those lessons
[Music]
you
[Music]
thank you for joining me for another
edition of Melina masters if you like
the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to do more these videos
for you guys and if you have a comment
or question I'd love to see it if you
want to leave it in the comment section
below so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode
[Music]
you
[Music]